-Welcome back. I'm talking
to Jessica Biel once again!
We are joined right now
by one of the stars
of her show, "Cruel Summer."
Please welcome
Chiara Aurelia!
Chiara, hey! Wow.
Chiara, it is great to meet you.
Thank you for doing this.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
It's great to meet you, too.
-There's been so much buzz
about this show.
It was Freeform's
most watched series debut ever,
by the way.
Congrats on that to both of you.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So cool.
-It's fantastic.
I was wondering
if either one of you, do you
ever look at memes and theories
that people have on the Internet
about who might have done what?
Or do you try to stay away
from all that stuff?
-I mean, me personally,
I actually kind of
don't look at anything.
I don't know
if I should do that.
I feel like people are like, "Do
you know what happened today?"
And I have literally no idea.
I kind of stay out of it.
But I have two friends who are
so obsessed with the show.
So I kind of get all my news,
all my media,
all my updates from them.
But they kind of tell me
what I want to hear.
So, who knows?
-it really is like
so many twists and turns,
as I was just talking
to Jess about.
It's very mysterious,
true crime.
But I heard as you were
filming it, the crew
and everyone didn't really know
who did what
until the last two episodes.
Is that true?
-Honestly, to tell you
the truth,
when the producers
and our creator Tia,
we all decided, okay,
let's let this be
sort of a surprise
for everyone as we go through
these episodes and shoot them.
From an actor's standpoint,
this is crazy.
I would literally not allow this
to happen.
if you were not going
to tell me the --
If I was in the show
and you're not going to tell me
what I'm working towards and --
How do I place my performance?
And I said this to these
girls and they're like,
"I actually prefer this.
I don't want to know."
-No, no, no.
-"I want to be focused."
-This is how young artists
are so much different
now these days.
-Young artists.
Chiara, you are --
The show is set in the '90s,
and you were born in 2020.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, just yesterday.
-Yeah. Congrats, I'm so happy.
But seriously, when you see
things from the '90s,
does it freak you out?
Do you go like,
"What are these things?"
-There was a couple
of moments like that.
I mean, the biggest story
that we have is that Olivia
did not know what a Walkman was.
So she was on set, kind of
staring at it with confusion,
and she was trying to, like, fit
it into her little fanny pack
and she couldn't figure it out.
It was very overwhelming.
I had more VHS tapes.
I used a Walkman.
It was kind of all the '90s
gadgets and stuff.
-The good old days, right,
Jimmy?
-Yeah. Oh, my goodness.
Are you kidding me? Yeah.
But I mean, Jessica,
you were on a teen drama.
Is it different
watching this now,
doing this teen drama
than it was when you were there?
-This is so different.
And I feel like television
has changed so much for,
you know, teen dramas
and Y.A. stories.
It's so much more complex.
The characters
are so much more developed,
in my opinion,
and it can really sink
your teeth into something.
I do feel like it's evolved
into such an amazing space
for actors and specifically
for young women.
-Good. Good for you. I love that
you did this and produce this.
-Thank you.
-It's a really fun show.
I want to show everyone a clip
from next week's episode
of "Cruel Summer."
Take a look.
-Do you think
Jamie will be here?
He can't resist the dunk tank.
-Are you the one
sitting in the hot seat?
-That's not funny.
-Yeah, you're right.
It's not. I went postal on that
girl-punching loser for you,
so why are you chasing him?
-I'm not.
It was just a question. Relax.
-Yeah.
You know Dad will murder
Jamie and you
if you even glance
in his direction, right?
-Dad's not here.
-Yeah, well, I am.
And last I checked,
Jamie is still with Kate,
so even if he is here,
won't she still be with him?
-That's kind of the idea.
-Jeannie, I swear.
-Look, I know what I'm doing.
-Yeah. Stalking Kate Wallis
is what you're --
-Shh!
-Whoa! "Shh!"
Jessica Biel, Chiara Aurelia!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Cruel Summer" airs Tuesdays
at 10:00 p.m. on Freeform
and on Hulu the next day.
So good to see you guys.
Thanks again for being here.